bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous voici à strasbourg au parlement
européen
un reportage de cette semaine nous
emmène en grèce où la crise sociale
s'aggrave
le taux de chômage explose la grèce où
le gouvernement a décidé sans prévenir
personne de fermer la télévision
publique
mais d'abord l'actualité après plusieurs
années de récession 57 millions
d'européens vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté alors l'europe s'enfonce tel
dans la misère c'est la question de la
semaine émeutes manifestations colère
ces trajets sont des histoires dernier
rempart de la lutte contre l'austérité
ses cris du peuple en grèce ou au
portugal en espagne en irlande aussi
c'est à chypre finalement on s'y
habituerait presque depuis cinq ans les
débuts de la crise
pas vraiment retour à la case misère
pour l'union européenne
les bulles immobilières ont explosé et
jeté dans les rues des familles entières
et en attendant on regarde mourir des
villages fantômes
même les autoroutes sont désertés alors
que le fmi avoue que le plan de
sauvetage en grèce fait une erreur voilà
qu'on nous annonce la fin de l'austérité
des paniques elle continue la rigueur
budgétaire
faut pas pousser alors est ce le retour
de la misère en europe
et nous voilà de retour à strasbourg au
parlement européen nous allons donc
parler de retour de la misère en europe
et pour évoquer cette question c'est
karima delli qui est avec nos bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
membre du groupe des verts ale vous êtes
surtout membre de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales
et comme vous voyez ces images d'émeutes
de manifestation quand vous voyez par
exemple la grèce est en récession depuis
plus de cinq ans maintenant qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque est ce que on a
régressé au niveau des conditions de vie
au sein de l'union européenne
la précarité a exposé la pauvreté
explosé et ça concerne toutes les
catégories de population que ce soit les
jeunes les retraités et même les
familles monoparentales aujourd'hui et
donc ça veut dire que le cap qu'on s'est
donné notamment le cav que la commission
et les chefs d'état c'est à dire le
cadre de l'austérité n'est pas le bon
cap aujourd'hui il faut penser plutôt à
des investissements pas à couper dans
les dépenses mais véritablement investir
pour pouvoir redonner un peu d'espoir à
l'ensemble des populations et créer des
filets de sécurité et à ce moment là on
verra réellement qu'une bouffée
d'oxygène et quand je parle de filets de
sécurité
on ne peut pas parler de la pauvreté et
ni de la misère sans les populations
parce que malheureusement souvent fait
pour elle
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous faire avec
elle là vous venez de rendre un rapport
qui a été saluée si je puis dire ce
qu'il a été il a eu du mal à être votée
sur la question du logement en europe le
logement en europe n'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne et de
surcroît le parlement européen
n'a pas vocation en fait à proposer des
directives est ce que c'est un pavé dans
la mare c'est pas un pavé dans la main
c'est la première fois que le parlement
s'engage de manière aussi claire pour
dire nous avons besoin du logement
social le logement ce n'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne mais
nous avons le droit à une aide au
logement c'est une obligation puisque
c'est un droit qui est reconnu par la
charte des droits fondamentaux et que
lui le logement intervient sur
différents au domaine l'efficacité
énergétique le volet emploi
le volet lutte contre l'exclusion le
volet également services d'intérêt
général est d'état etc et dans mon
rapport justement pour la première fois
les députés européens demandent un cadre
européen des politiques du logement
notamment du logement social pour
véritablement avancé pour plus de
logements sociaux mais aussi à monter
sur cette europe sociale là vous avez
pointé dans ce rapport la question de la
spéculation immobilière et les bulles on
l'a vu notamment en irlande on l'a vu en
espagne surtout on assiste en fait à des
on voit aujourd'hui des villages
fantômes qui sont complètement vide on
estime qu'il ya 700 mille logements en
espagne qui sont aujourd'hui non occupés
laon l'état aujourd'hui comment vous
régler cette question là alors très
simplement le rapport dit bien que plus
on aura un parc de logements sociaux
importants plus on va éviter les bulles
immobilières
ça veut dire que vous dites stop aux
propriétaires quoi on dit réellement
aujourd'hui il faut plus de logements
sociaux parce que c'est un véritable
levier pour lutter contre la crise
sociale la crise économique mais aussi
la crise écologique et face notamment à
un vrai problème vous évoquez notamment
l'espagne aujourd'hui dans le rapport
ont dit clairement que non il faut
lutter contre les expulsions notamment
des familles qui n'arrivent plus à payer
leurs crédits hypothécaires ça a été
reconnue notamment par la cour
européenne de justice ait reconnu par le
parlement européen
maintenant mais les soigne aussi à votr
moratoire de deux ans sur les expulsions
vous vous oui oui avec ceux ci soient
généralisable sur tout le territoire et
la rhonelle on a plusieurs
expérimentations au niveau européen on a
essayé de le demander notamment de
mettre en place justement des politiques
de prévention et d'éviter les expulsions
on l'a on s'est battus au parlement mais
malheureusement les conservateurs
et les libéraux sont encore dans une
logique du tous propriétaires qui
malheureusement nous en mai nous a
emmenés dans le mur et n'a pas été
adopté mais cela n'est pas très grave
puisque dans le rapport on trouve
également une protection qui est majeur
notamment pour les populations les plus
les plus précaires notamment c'est de
lutter contre la vacance des logements
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas assez de
logements sociaux
il faut construire dont il faut lutter
contre la vacance des logements et pour
la première fois le parlement européen
demande à l'ensemble des états membres
de fixer un quota minimum de logements
sociaux notamment dans les zones tendues
vous voyez là je veux dire en riant une
application de la loi sru comme telle
qu'on la connaît la rance qui oblige en
fait les communes avoir 25 % de
logements sociaux sur leur territoire
mais cela au niveau européen voilà que
si je comprends bien vous la militante
de jeudi noir qui est donc une
association qui se posent sur ce champ
du logement et notamment du logement
social
vous êtes en train de donner plutôt un
satisfecit à la france sur la manière
dont elle gère la question du logement
bah on peut faire crédit à la france
qu'elle avance notamment sur cette
question de logement social mais elle ne
va pas assez loin parce qu'on ne
construit pas on n'est pas aujourd'hui
dans les objectifs à atteindre
malheureusement va pas les atteindre 7
cette année
et moi je tire la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le fait qu'en france y faire aussi
beaucoup plus de logements très sociaux
parce que malheureusement l'accès à des
logements sociaux est de plus en plus un
parcours du combattant pour les jeunes
les plus précaires les plus pauvres on
voit bien quand même qu'on est dans une
conjoncture budgétaire très contrainte
le budget européen qui sera peut-être en
passe d'être adopté le mois prochain
baisse considérablement les crédits au
fond est-ce qu'on peut pas dire que
votre rapport et ses voeux de deux de
pointe et les fonds structurels sur la
question du logement sur cette précarité
énergétique est ce que c'est pas un voeu
pieux c'était pas voeu pieux parce que
d'une part l'union européenne investit
déjà via les fonds structurels dans le
logement social aujourd'hui nous sommes
en pleine négociation notamment sur le
fléchage des fonds européens oui ce sera
une priorité
l'union européenne va investir davantage
bien les fonds structurels dans le
logement social est également dans le
logement privé et via aussi notamment
des vins investissement
par la banque publique d'investissement
donc ce qu'on appelle la bo y voyez on
est en train d'avancer mais je voudrais
juste insister sur un nouveau fléau
parce que je pense que c'est maintenant
qu'il faut tirer la scène d'alarmé avec
deux chiffres il y a aujourd'hui en
europe entre 50 125 millions de
personnes qui sont dans une précarité
énergétique qui n'arrivent plus à se
chauffer qui n'arrivent plus à payer
notamment leurs factures et ben c'est
une question de rénovation thermique et
l'europe finance déjà justement cette
rénovation thermique et a permis en
l'espace de deux ans la rénovation de
70000 logements sociaux en france et la
création directe plus de 15000 emplois
locaux non délocalisables m'écouter
merci beaucoup karima delli je rappelle
effectivement que on estime qu'il ya 57
millions d'européens qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté donc
effectivement c'est un grand chantier
pour l'union et pour les parlementaires
merci karima delli d'avoir été notre
invité aujourd'hui nous on continue sur
sur cette émission sur la question de la
syrie vous savez que bachar el-assad est
accusé par la communauté internationale
d'utiliser des armes chimiques dans son
pays et nous avons voulu savoir comment
les télévisions étrangères avait traité
la question c'est un zapping réalisé par
aurélie la face
problèmes respiratoires pupilles
dilatées les blessés des hôpitaux
syriens sont surtout les écrans comme
autant de preuves de l'utilisation des
armes chimiques dans le pays sur la bbc
sept habitants témoignent il y avait une
odeur suffocante horrible on ne pouvait
plus du tout respire et tout mon corps
était comme fatigué il perdait tous ses
sens on avait l'impression d'être mort
je n'y voyais plus rien et je n'ai plus
rien vu pendant trois ou quatre jours
au plan international les états prennent
position et c'est de s'organiser mais ce
n'est pas encore l'unité
la grande bretagne a annoncé détenir des
preuves sûres concernant l'utilisation
de gaz sarin preuve confirmée par la
france qui n'exclut pas l'intervention
militaire pendant ce temps la rencontre
entre les etats-unis la russie et l'onu
a débuté à genève pour préparer la
conférence internationale sur la syrie
appelée genève 2 dont la date n'a pas
encore été fixée pas de date pour une
conférence internationale et au niveau
européen comme toujours pas de position
commune
l'embargo sur les armes est levé mais
ensuite libre à chaque état dans livrés
ou non la rtbf juge sévèrement
l'indécision du celloises un bisou par
ci un bisou par là devant les caméras
les patrons des différentes diplomatie
européenne donne presque l'impression
d'une parfaite harmonie
ce n'est qu'une illusion une fois réunis
ils affichent leurs divergences pour en
arriver à ce qui s'appelle un échec
les européens en échec sur la question
syrienne c'est nicolas gros verheyde qui
est avec nous pour en parler merci
d'être avec nous bonjour bonjour vous
êtes spécialiste des questions de
défense notamment sur l'union européenne
et partout ailleurs si je puis dire et
vous vous dirigez le blog bruxelles 2
points eu comme vous voyez ces images de
fin de responsables européens qui se
font effectivement la bise et qui sont
dans une certaine léthargie sur la
question syrienne qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
ça m'inspire que depuis deux ans on
parle de solutions politiques depuis
deux ans les européens en ont mis rien
en place pour une solution politique
du coup on discute que d'embargo sur les
armes alors qu'on devrait discuter plan
de paix envoi d'émissaires solution
intermédiaire conférence internationale
ce qui est la solution politique pour
l'instant les européens n'ont mis en
place
rien de tout ça et pourtant la ligue
arabe a envoyé un émissaire
il y en a même eu deux ou trois qui ont
chacun démissionner devant
l'impossibilité de la tâche donc est-ce
qu'il ya encore une solution politique
la ligue arable effectivement pas
l'union européenne oui il ya pour moi il
ya encore on n'a pas essayé tous les
tous les vecteurs de la solution
politique le problème c'est qu'il faut
associer tous les acteurs de la région
donc à part de monde on exclut un des
acteurs qui éliront qui est un acteur
principal
on exclut toute solution politique donc
ça ne sert à rien de parler de solution
politique si on ne dialogue pas en gros
le dialogue
il se passe pas avec les amis il se
passe avec les ennemis donc il faut
associer l'iran il faut associer le
hezbollah le
la partie libanaise et le hezbollah
voire voir toutes les parties vraiment
associer avec des intermédiaires neutre
on peut pas demander au qatar à la barre
et l'arabie saoudite ou à la russie aux
états unis d'être les interminables
neutre faut trouver des intermédiaires
note pour assurer la réunion des deux
parties ce qu'est le classique on
associe le corps arles caen b et au
milieu des nôtres les européens où
certains europe 1 aurait pu jouer les
notes qu'ils ont pas joué les neutres ou
quoi parce qu'ils sont faibles
parce qu'ils sont faibles parce qu'ils
sont impuissants parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas et qu'ils ont le toulonnais sur la
question de la syrie c'est quoi c'est la
régionalisation du conflit on est dans
un espèce de maelström on ne veut pas
s'en mêler
c'est parce que je pense qu'il ya un
manque de volonté ou le tout la solution
européenne était dire on appuie les
efforts de l'onu et la ligue arabe
il ya en gros on fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour ça mais ça ne suffit pas si on veut
être un acteur on doit pas appuyer les
efforts d'un autre acteur on doit
proposer ses services
je pense que là c'est une erreur
fondamentale des européens
là on assiste aussi aujourd'hui à 7
franchissement de la ligne rouge dont
barack obama parlait qui est
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
on a quand même de plus en plus de
preuves sur l'utilisation notamment du
gaz sarin la question de la levée de
l'embargo et de la livraison d'armes a
été posée qu'en est il en fait de tout
ça alors il y à il ya deux choses il ya
les armes chimiques
l'ani rouges s'étaient unis rouge bideau
faut aller très clair il n'y a pas de
ligne rouge
y a rien dans le droit international qui
dit que quand yann alchimie qu'on a le
droit d'employer la fin c'est obama qui
l'a dit c'est obama mais on a fait
bouger on appelle reviendra ce mois là
mais c'est une ligne rouge bidon qui et
qui d'ailleurs s'est écroulé au moment
la ligne rouge était franchie
c'est comme quand vous franchissez la
ligne jaune personne n'a sifflé donc
vous pouvez rouler donc il ya eu un feu
vert à l'emploi d'armes chimiques la
nuit rouge chez transforma en feu vert
ça c'est le premier fait pour moi la
ligne rouge a déjà été franchi quand on
viole le droit international humanitaire
c'est ça la vraie ligne rouge
la vraie ligne rouge quand on bombarde
et hôpitaux qu'on tue des civils des
enfants qu'on s'attaque aux au médecin
après tous les efforts qu'on ne
s'attaque pas uniquement aux combattants
donc la ligne rouge est franchie depuis
de plusieurs temps la vraie ligne rouge
en fait je pense pour la plupart des
acteurs internationaux c'est que le
conflit ne déborde pas violemment dehors
des frontières
et pourtant les regarde on voit que la
le lion est quand même un peu touché en
tant que sarlat surgi donc ça reste un
peu touché savatan qu'en fait pour les
américains la vraie ligne rouge
pense que c'est israël pour les russes
la vraie ligne rouge c'est leur base
donc tant ces deux grosses lignes rouges
sont pas franchies personne personne ne
bougera pas ce que personne n'a intérêt
à bouger les russes bloque toute façon
toute résolution au conseil de sécurité
les occidentaux ne veulent pas passer en
dehors du conseil de sécurité la leçon
de l'irak a payé
donc pour l'instant le conflit continue
il continuera d'avoir des morts on est à
cent mille morts les armes chimiques ont
fait un certain nombre de morts mais
n'ont pas fait l'essentiel des mains
l'essentiel des morts est fait par xam
conventionnelle donc temps que les
syriens se battent dans leur pays pour
la communauté internationale fouette
chimiques ya pas de problème merci
nicolas gros verheyde d'avoir été notre
invité nous on continue avant de
retrouver kathia gilder et son invité
direction la grèce après 50 crise nous
avons été à la rencontre d'un peuple à
l'agonie là bas le taux de suicide a
augmenté de 26% en une année c'est un
reportage de florence maurice et de
pavlos canada is
6 avril 2012 un pharmacien retraité
criblé de dettes se suicident à deux pas
du parlement grec
un geste politique pour dénoncer
l'austérité c'est une honte c'est une
grande honte
cela aurait pu être l'un d'entre nous ça
aurait pu être quelqu'un de notre
famille
si ça continue nous allons tous nous
suicider les grecs prennent soudain
conscience de la crise morale qui secoue
leur pays avec piso une association des
jo sur endettés on a pris très tôt la
mesure de ce malaise ici 25 juristes
bénévoles viennent en aide aux victimes
des coupes budgétaires
bonjour on va voir où en est votre
dossier mariana a poussé la porte en
à l'époque je me sentais coupable
extrêmement cropper
je me disais que j'avais fait beaucoup
d'erreurs j'étais totalement désespéré
je ne sortais plus de la maison je ne
voulais plus me battre je pleurais tout
le temps
j'étais envahi par la tristesse et une
profonde envie d'autodestruction parmi
les personnes suivies avec piso quatre
se sont déjà suicidé les bénévoles ont
même dû faire appel à des psychologues
pour les aider à soutenir les plus
désespérés comme beaucoup mariana se
croyait à l'abri
elle était fonctionnaire un emploi
stable bien payé aujourd'hui elle ignore
si elle pourra garder cet appartement
acheté à crédit
après des années de croissance
insouciante en grèce la crise a fait
vaciller ses certitudes à droite
kavanagh cana en fait je n'ai rien fait
de fou j'ai juste agi comme tout le
monde il faut se souvenir qu'à cette
époque là les banques nous envoyait des
offres de prêts tous les jours
si marianne a refait surface grâce au
soutien psychologique reçu un épisode
beaucoup n'ont pas cette chance dans une
grèce très religieuse le suicide reste
un sujet tabou
consultez est une décision difficile
coûteuse aussi le secteur de la santé
est à l'agonie un tiers des grecs n'a
plus d'assurance maladie ce centre
médical a été créé en 2011 pour répondre
à l'urgence on n'a pas de gynécologues
aujourd'hui si elles viennent je dis ici
des médecins bénévoles se relaie pour
offrir gratuitement soins et médicaments
aux exclus du système de santé
vous avez retrouvé le passé merci
beaucoup maria et psychologue elle
consulte ici cinq heures par semaine je
sens qu'il ya vraiment des choses qui se
sont débloquées en moi si tous les jours
on voit arriver des bébés de 2 kg alors
qu'ils devraient peser 4 saut énorme
mais beaucoup de gens considèrent le
soutien psychologique comme un luxe dans
ce chaos ambiant
on est en train de fabriquer une
génération de grecs désemparés et en
colère de vider la jeunesse de tout son
potentiel de toutes ses capacités je
n'exagère pas c'est un génocide
en deux ans la consommation
d'antidépresseurs a bondi en grèce celle
de drogue aussi tout comme les
contaminations au vih
deux fois par semaine place omonia
médecins du monde accueille les
toxicomanes donner les premiers soins
degrés la grèce a même sa nouvelle
drogue
l'a6a composé de liquide de batterie et
de détergents j'ai des amis qui en
prennent régulièrement en deux ans
d'utilisation ils sont plus atteints que
moi après 20 ans d'héroïne
je suis déjà allé les voir chez eux ils
deviennent fous il se tape la tête
contre les murs c'est totalement irréel
avoir 2 euros le shoot contre 7 pour de
l'héroïne l'a6a est la drogue de la
crise
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge mais
la grèce s'accroche à ses valeurs
refuges famille et religion depuis le
début de la crise
le père thomas est sur tous les fronts
il a triplé ses distributions de
nourriture et multiplie les activités à
destination des enfants
une fois qu'on aura dépassé la crise je
crois que la situation sera meilleure
qu'avant et car à cause des difficultés
les gens ont dû renoncer à
l'individualisme absolue et renouer avec
la solidarité c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait perdu après six années de
récession
la grèce espère une timide reprise
économique en 2014
mais nul ne sait encore combien de temps
ou de génération il faudra pour réparer
la crise morale qui mine le pays
reportage signé florence maurice à
athènes avec lilly a shoe crise
économique sociale et sanitaire la grèce
est au coeur de l'actualité on en parle
avec notre invité
rodi kratsa bonjour vous êtes député
grec du parti populaire européen qui
regroupe le la droite et le centre
droite ici au parlement européen et grec
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques et monétaires cette semaine
coup de théâtre en grèce puisque il ya
eu une annonce de la fermeture de la
radio télévision publique
la police est monté sur la montagne pour
éteindre l'émetteur principal de la
télévision sans que les journalistes
aient eu le temps de dire au revoir
c'est quand même un cas unique en europe
puisque j'ai vu que la dernière fois que
c'était produit c'était en 1967 avec la
dictature des colonels
est ce que pour vous c'est une violation
de la démocratie
écoutez ne fait pas des comparaisons
pareil la grèce est un pays en récession
économique sixième année de récession
économique est une société en crise
comme votre reportage a évoqué de
l'autre côté il y à une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui chez les grecs
je sais pas si votre reportage a pu
constater ça aussi
les gags sont dont les cafés saut dont
le règne dans les familles autour de la
famille pour de fêtes familiales pour
des fêtes religieuses elles ont une
confiance en l'avenir malgré la
tristesse malgré la souffrance et la sur
ceux des systèmes fermés
vous imaginez comment alors la décision
et dit qu'il a la situation difficile
que le gouvernement après en dedans
tentative de restructurer le secteur
public de radio-télévision est un
secteur un homme non productifs nos
compétitive a pris la décision après des
grèves continuent parce que malgrè son
fonctionnement en ligne et mettait pas
toujours et partout à cause de grève
continue il a pris la décision de fermer
les secteurs et de préparer déjà le
projet la halle à l'ouverture la
création d'un autre secteur avec moins
pour deux personnes au moins de
personnel et sur instructeur plus
rationaliser les structures modernes qui
pourra a quand même satisfaire aux
besoins d'un service public et qui ne va
peser autant aux contribuables grecs
est ce que le gouvernement grec qui a
surpris tout le monde de court en
prenant cette décision n'aurait pas pu
quand même informé avant des salariés
puisque même l'union européenne a été
surprise le président de l'ufr l'union
des radios télés l'isthme de combat a
critiqué cette décision
vous comprenez son fils après je ne peux
pas je ne peux pas vous parler de la
communication du lit
cette communication entre les acteurs
publics grecs
l association européenne ça je ne peux
pas vous dire que c'était déjà leur
avais inévitable ça je ne vais pas vous
dire c'est qu'ils étaient nécessaires
c'est pour ça que malgré les réactions
des fonctionnaires qu'on peut très bien
comprendre quelqu'un qui marque son
travail et il a quand même dans une
partie de l'adresse de la population est
une satisfaction qui est quand même là
un bouleversement qui va rationaliser
le secteur public parce que pour le
moment les effets de la crise de
l'austérité de cette adaptation rapide
budgétaire c'est là le secteur privé du
pays
jodar équilibre à le chômage c'est dans
les secteurs privés alors si on demande
aux entreprises privées de faire leur
restructuration de rationaliser de faire
d'eux des exportations des faire plus de
choses avec moi - du mouvement des frais
imaginez comment ces charters privé qui
voit baiser sur ses épaules
cette adaptation à cette crise et exige
du gouvernement de m capable de faire
mieux son ménage dont les secteurs
publics mais malgré ça il y a une une
prise des précautions pour les
fonctionnaires deux grands secteurs de
radio télévision
ils ne seront pas dehors ils seront
hissés rompt il son enfant quand même
d'abord une priorité pour les concours
d'entrée dans l'aisne
la nouvelle structure qui va naître on
espère bien bientôt et de l'autre côté
ils peuvent aussi passer de les concours
ou des services qui embauchent encore
comme les hôpitaux les services sociaux
etc
quand on voit notre reportage on se dit
que l'état du pays et quand même
et quand même grave et difficile société
en crise mais certains voient pourtant
économistes prédisent un retour de la
croissance en 2014
est ce que vous y croyez ou nice on
espère on travaille pour ça
mais vous savez il faut prendre des
mesures difficiles des décisions
difficiles et cette balance cet
équilibre constant que le gouvernement
doit faire ni en trop
la rationalisation économique budgétaire
est quand même la protection des
travailleurs de la société des gens de
chômeurs est toujours difficile
vous pouvez comprendre continent ceux-ci
comment c'est difficile de prendre des
mesures que nous on les voit urgent et
nécessaire parce que il aura un coût
social et politique qui est très souvent
insupportable
voilà nous on a tous les jours des
décisions de pareilles décisions apprend
en même temps les politiques héritées
appliquée pour la grèce depuis des
années son sont un peu remise en cause
le fonds monétaire international a lui
même reconnu qu'il avait peut-être fait
fausse route en imposant une austérité
aussi aussi forte est ce que c'est le
cas voilà vous savez moi je critiquais
même sur mon plateau plusieurs fois elle
le programme appliqué en grèce au début
tout le monde a cru que c'était la
troïka qui a l'expérience internationale
les troquets l'union monétaire dans la
centrale qui ont une expérience
internationale
l intérêt de voir des résultats positifs
rapidement et les programmes et les bons
il faut les suivre
nous notre parti a contesté de le
premier maul ce programme et parce que
les griefs n'est pas contre eux mais
n'hésitez pas il n'était pas équilibrée
dans les deux volets austérité et et
mesure des soutenances de l'économie et
de 2,2 soit la croissance oui mais voilà
on est là aujourd'hui il faut s'en
sortir et c'est très difficile pour la
classe politique et pour la société
grecque
c'est nos soucis quotidiens mais c'était
je peux vous dire c'est que vraiment le
gouvernement doit aller en avant n'est
pas le souhait et il n'a pas le choix
d'aller en arrière mais la société
grecque
elle est très solidaire vous l'avez pu
pu constater que ce après cette
solidarité vraiment elle est très
nécessaire vous donner cet espoir aux
gens non seulement déçu porter le fer de
leurs plans pour le lendemain
eh bien merci beaucoup rudi garcia sous
le modèle votre intérêt de l'intérêt que
vous portez à la société doit vous
laisser aller dans l'hémicycle puisqu'il
ya des votes en ce moment même c'est la
fin de cette émission je vous souhaite
une très bonne suite de programmes et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour un autre
numéro d' europe hebdo